what's going on guys this is Sal from
the YouTube channel comic pop Rob asked
me to stop by and talk about some of the
most Opie moments in spider-man history
and I was more than happy to oblige so
let's jump into them the first one I
want to talk about is from amazing
spider-man number 328 written by David
mecha lining with art by Todd McFarlane
this one is fun because it's in the
middle of two separate events the first
one is the Marvel centric event acts of
vengeance while the other is the captain
universe saga of spider-man's adventures
so the setup here is that in acts of
vengeance the super villains all got
together and traded superheroes so in
the beginning of the story Sebastian
Shaw of the Hellfire Club has been
tasked with defeating spider-man but
rather than get his hands dirty he
decides to hire The Incredible Hulk to
take care of the job for him
luckily for Shaw The Incredible Hulk was
in his gray mr. Fixit phase which means
he was more than willing to get his
hands dirty for a dishonest buck Hulk
goes to New York City and starts tearing
things up which does get the attention
of spider-man and results in a little
bit of a fight
spider-man displays an increased
Augmented strength due to the Captain
Universe ability which catches the Hulk
by surprise at this point Bruce banners
personality starts to leak through so
the Hulk decides to table this fight for
another day he names the time in the
place and then takes off round 2 results
in an even bigger fight on Roosevelt
Island until some kids wind up walking
in the crossfire
spider-man desperate to keep them safe
lands an uppercut on the Incredible Hulk
knocking him into orbit using another
newfound captain Universe power
spider-man flies out to meet the
Incredible Hulk in orbit and returns him
safely back to earth grateful for not
being left to die in the cold vacuum of
space the Hulk calls off the job and
then moves on leaving spider-man to
wonder just what in the heck is going on
around here but that's a story for
another time for sucker punching the
Hulk into space and mitigating his
temper not to mention a knock-down
drag-out fight that is super cool to
look at because McFarland's pencils I
would say this counts as an epic Opie
moment for spider-man
this next Opie moment requires no
augmentation to straight-up spider
powers from amazing spider-man number
270 spider-man vs. Fire Lord written by
Tom DeFalco with art by Ron friends
former Herald of Galactus and infused
with the power cosmic fire Lord has
given the entire Avengers team a run for
their money in an earlier story Fire
Lord had been humiliated by spider-man
taking his staff away from him and
throwing it into the East River and so
fire Lord returns to earth to get
revenge on spider-man this entire issue
is one huge fight scene where Fire Lord
throws everything is
at spider-man and spider-man desperately
trying to either to get away or rescue
civilians who are caught in harm's way
the entire first half of the fight is
just spider-man jumping out of the way
of fire Lords blasts eventually the
fight leads to a construction site where
crews are about to demo a huge building
spider-man narrowly escapes leaving fire
Lord inside before a crew member decides
to level the entire building enraged by
the attempt on his life by pathetic
humans Fire Lord fires wildly from his
staff a stray blast blows up a gas
station and levels an entire city block
of abandoned buildings desperate humbled
and out of ideas
spider-man decides to take on Fire Lord
head-on in a blinding flurry of speed
strength and ability spider-man attacks
Fire Lord from all sides desperate to
keep Fire Lord at bay until the
civilians can escape and maybe some help
can arrive until Captain America's hand
on spider-man shoulder indicates that
he's won and Fire Lord is down this
one's okay because spider-man
single-handedly defeats a Herald of
Galactus this next one's fun because
it's very silly it comes from Silver
Surfer number 14 and involves the Silver
Surfer feeling sorry for himself and
flying around New York City and it was
produced by Stan Lee and John Besh Emma
spider-man's on his way home when he
accidentally snags a web line onto the
silver surfers passing board there's a
bit of a mid-air tussle before
spider-man plummets to the ground not
wanting to kill the Porsche love the
Silver Surfer fires a blast of power
cosmic at the fire Rajan below the
sudden geyser of water cushion
spider-man's fall but bruises his ego an
enraged spider-man gives chase to Silver
Surfer and what follows is an epic
rooftop fight across the city the
National Guard becomes involved
attacking the Silver Surfer with
reckless abandon ultimately Silver
Surfer saves a little boy who was caught
in the crossfire the spider-man learns a
lesson about I don't know judging a book
by its cover or something for me it's
okay because Spiderman went toe to toe
with the Silver Surfer and walked away
with nary a scratch this one is a
classic because it comes from amazing
spider-man number one and this fight is
featured on the cover written of course
by Stan Lee with art by Steve Ditko
unable to cash checks miss wrestling
career while also wanting to live up to
that power responsibility thing for
Uncle Ben he decides to audition to work
for the Fantastic Four for a salary of
course unable to break into their
private elevator he decides to go the
more conventional route through the
window which triggers their high-tech
super science security system once he
gets through that though the real fight
begins as he takes a major punch from
the thing to the face he tosses the
thing like an action figure onto the
Human Torch and then webs up mr.
fantastics gigantic elastic hand the
Invisible Girl goes invisible and
attempts to sneak up on him with
laso for some reason which triggers
spider-man's spider-sense he winds up
using the lasso against her and spins
her like a top
suddenly the Human Torch encircle
spider-man in a ring of flame which
Spiderman easily links out of
spider-man's plan was to bide his time
until human torches flame went down but
mr. fantastic puts a stop to the fight
and asks what exactly is going on here
they revealed her a nonprofit
organization which spider-man scoff sad
and leaves disappointed he picks apart
the entire Fantastic Four one by one
and while Human Torch does give him a
run for his money I have no doubt
spider-man would have figured out a way
to put him out and finally in one of the
most Opie displays I've ever seen in
continuity spider-man picks apart the
entire x-men and yes even Wolverine
written by Jim shooter with art by Mike
Zack in Secret Wars number three select
members of the supervillain and
superhero community have been
sequestered on a far distant planet
known as battle world magneto is off on
his own and the x-men are musing whether
they should join him because humanity
will never accept them which seems kind
of self-defeating but what do I do
spider-man here is only the last few
moments of the conversation and drops in
to stop them from turning Conan a
superhero comrades or so he thinks
he drops through the skylight and in one
move with both hands he takes out
Cyclops and Professor X spider-man webs
Colossus his face before he can clobber
REM and rogue to a nearby pipe keeping
her from flying by yeah maneuvers
Nightcrawler and douses him in a heaping
pile of webs and just before Wolverine
can get the drop on him spider-man
literally just backhands him across the
room
spider-man leaps out of the way of
cyclopses concussive blasts and makes
his escape
unfortunately for spider-man Professor X
comes to and removes the entire
altercation from spider-man's mind look
he takes out five members of the x-men
before Professor X mine way me Zim so
I'd say that's pretty Oh pay and that
concludes some of spider-man's most
opium or are one more in Marvel Comics
Civil War number 7 written by Mark
Miller with art by Steve McNiven
spider-man switches size from Iron Man
to Captain America and in a climactic
battle between all the superheroes
spider-man sets his sights on mr.
fantastic but in order to reach him he
has to get through four different
super-powered characters in a stunning
display of power and grace masterfully
depicted by Steve McNiven
spider-man takes out Bishop doc Samson
radioactive man and the blizzard before
dealing a crushing blow to mr. fantastic
himself before being kicked into
unconsciousness Reed Richards watches in
awe and remarks aloud amazing
- which spider-man replies spectacular
spectacular indeed spider-man and so
those are some of the most Opie moments
in spider-man's history you got another
one let us know in the comments I'm Sal
from comic pop
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you